what is this new personality you're
adopting you what's going on here
where's the camera i have to be like what's
up what's up man last time i was on here i was
a little shy i'm going to show you nothing but
confidence now i actually know what i'm talking
about because i've seen batman movies before
what did you think about this movie i really
liked seeing batman in the daytime that was very
fun and seeing him in water was also really cool
what did you think about the movie cool
the movie was cool i loved robert pattinson
as batman it was interesting seeing his
chemistry with um jeffrey wright zoe kravitz
it was fun seeing him shooting yawn in
the middle of you talking i'm so sick
this wasn't the snyder cut but it was all so long
so some of these were just like facts about the
movie they just said batman was in the water
the advantage of a car and i kind of like the
movie fun movie really it was really pretty
like looking visually great
shots love the use of colors
okay just
yeah i need i need the banter
bro you're doing great yeah yeah
my person is my favorite thing tonight
what's going on there reject nation we are
at cinemark today because i can't imagine
watching this movie any other way than in the
freaking movie theaters got a private watch
party here's how much a private watch party
is you give up to 30 people for this thing
and i literally got like 29 people in the theater
right now all of them are fans of batman so i was
like look when this movie's done i want to
get some genuine fan reactions afterwards
about half of them agreed to be on camera
cinemark rocks right john nod the camera yeah
we like it here now we got michael tesla with
us i call him josh gad that's just what i call
spot tonight you guys know you've heard it
before you can't go to airports or anywhere
sum up how do you feel about this
movie it was the batman film that i
didn't know i needed and i didn't ask for uh but
that being said while i feel really depressed
uh after watching it it was actually a really
amazing film kind of surprised the heck out of me
it was nice to have like a really raw murderous
kind of mystery robert penson he was amazing i
think he did a great job as like a young angsty
batman and i think commissioner gordon was just
actually lieutenant gordon in this movie
lieutenant you sound like a [ __ ] idiot
michael you know go you're done i hope you enjoyed
cinemark today all right guys this is callie um
she's my best friend i've known her for ages cali
how are you today it's great meeting you today
it's great meeting you today too i don't know
anything about you at all what did you think about
this movie i really liked it um it was cool to see
batman kind of not have it all figured out because
like none of this stuff would have happened in
christian bales gotham the transition of robert
pattinson from my like sparkly teenage dream to
this like kind of burly mysterious like zaddy type
role i really really enjoyed that you described
what most people say about me so that's really
cool to hear actually i noticed mark hansen's
like really white in this movie which actually
kind of works for the batman i saw like several
people just nod their heads like he's really white
i know you got to get out of here but thank
you for coming and i hope you like the
time it's cinemark say something
nice about cinemark i love cinemark
sellouts all right guys we got matt reeves with
us today kyle kyle i know that was that wasn't my
joke brother who john said that i just said it and
you got shirt at them we got uh kyle with us who
got a lot of crap in our spider-man video that's
right i just can't imagine running right now
what did you think about the batman very
passionate marvel fan here uh never been into dc
this is probably my all-time favorite superhero
movie period wow what a statement you're not
thinking you're being too reactionary right now
no no no no it's honestly this actually seemed
really calm about the whole thing so i believe
this is the first time i feel like a character
from the comics has hit their potential
the way that they should have all along
like no marvel characters ever done this no dc
character outside of this has ever done this
everything i've wanted from this character
since i was a little kid you realize that you
got crap for not being all that into spider-man
no way home now you're gonna get crap for saying
this is the best movie ever yeah it is nearly
perfect i believe that you believe that it was
all right goodbye matt hey stefan hey
how's it going now a few months ago
when we were at kyle's birthday i remember
like catching up with you and we were like
dude i think this batman movie we were like this
could be it the closest thing to like rival the
dark knight i'm not gonna have you just compare
it just because that would be [ __ ] up but uh
what did you think about the batman be honest
okay well like you said i went into this kind
of expecting this to be my favorite batman movie
the riddler is my favorite batman villain so it
had everything going for it and it managed to over
deliver on that for me i fully loved everything
they did in this movie especially with the riddler
turning him into basically like a horror villain
and he's like kind of like jigsaw zodiac the whole
time so i had such a blast with that kind of just
the darkness of the whole thing you can kind
of see that in matt reeve's direction it really
felt like the batman movie i've always wanted
everyone here is a bunch of pretentious shills
no one really feels this way about the batman i'm
genuinely i loved this one i could see everything
i wanted like i couldn't believe what i just
watched you know there's only so far i can
pull the mic and you just keep getting further
and further you're getting closer and i'm just
like you're in my space but i'm just like you get
comfortable here we have to be on camera again all
right olivia one of the first things that we ever
bonded over was your love for comics specifically
batman you know she's more honest than i've
ever been in my entire life about anything
everyone should know that yeah i think this is an
incredible journey visceral raw that we go on with
yeah all right sorry sorry i couldn't talk for
a second i'm going to suffer the consequences
of that interruption it's an incredible journey
that we know let's wrap this up i think this is
the best comic book movie i've ever seen it's not
meant to be a superhero film so don't go in with
that mindset this is a comic book movie and it's
incredible would you say he's your favorite batman
yes i think did i put too much pressure on you
right there no i'm just trying to compare in my
head all the batman do you want me just blurt out
and i have to compare quickly yeah i want you to
go to the bathroom because i can tell you gotta go
to the bathroom all right i love you i'll see you
later all right so greg asked me to do this in 60
and 90 seconds i'll do my best i said 30 to 60 but
okay you get 98. i think this film really nailed
for the first time ever i mean we got glimpse of
it and you know the christian bale uh films and
some of the other uh batman iterations of what
it truly means for batman to be the detective and
i really felt like this film really nailed that i
mean this film is just non-stop detective work i
gotta say this movie the cinematography in this
film is just unbelievable some of the aerial shots
and the the car chases the hand-to-hand combat
scenes really quick it's great to behold on a
cinemark screen isn't it all those shots for sure
definitely you gotta see it at a cinemark screen
by the way if you go into this film expecting an
all-out action-packed batman film in my opinion
you're going to be a little bit disappointed if
you go in going in with like more of a character
study you know of batman i think you're going to
appreciate it a lot more because that's what i
really appreciated about this film and what matt
reeves uh did here is it's just it's a real
character study of batman and and you know
of gotham and and some of these criminals that
we get and am i going to your time is up cue that
oscar music all right guys i met our shot for the
first time a few weeks ago and we became really
really like we just bonded i don't wanna say
really close we bought it a lot no we're really
close now we're pretty close i'll take it i just
felt a little self-conscious say at the time what
did you think about the batman i loved it i just
thought it was stunning like that it was a noir
right when it started i was like oh [ __ ] this is
what we're doing i like that batman could get hurt
zoe kravitz stunning every time she was on screen
you're just like oh [ __ ] this woman is beautiful
they both looked hot they both look great together
that's what i really liked about it the music was
great the entire score just added to the whole
thing i thought this was the closest to the
batman animated series in terms of tone and i
really liked that i felt like i was actually
watching that come to life gotham was like
really dark and really gritty okay i'm done
cool done follow our shot on social media he
has some shirtless photos all right aaron so
i watched all the batman movies leading into this
one this is hands down the most authentic gotham
we've ever seen this is the best performance by a
batman the most nuanced performance from a batman
we've seen to date robert pattinson has so many
layers to his performance and the world and the
noir detective aspect of this film was unlike any
other film we've seen before and quite frankly
lives up to the potential of what matt reeves
said in making a noir detective film i okay
did you write that down like you said that so
confidently like you went all deep voice and you
looked right in the camera you just said it all
right did you write that down and like i'm going
to have this [ __ ] so ready to go by the time i
get on at a time limit so i said i was going to
[ __ ] do it you nailed that i have a couple small
issues with the film but it doesn't detract at the
quality of it the cinematography is beautiful
the uh the music is beautiful i'm finished
get it out of the way i don't think the way
that they used uh the batmobile felt authentic
that is my one criticism also the riddler was
uh both amazing creepy and hilarious there's
no bouncing back literally everyone's removed back
here everyone back here just went what's he saying
here wait a minute wait a minute i'm not done
because i sell more to say about this movie
this movie is the most batman we've ever seen
batman and it's not about him being bruce
wayne it's about him learning to become bruce
wayne he is batman and we slowly go through
his journey of becoming more like bruce wayne
the most you guys were already sure what is
and if you guys didn't mention it you can't just
come back up here let you know colin farrell was
really good that was also really good you're gonna
do what you did last time what did i do last time
it just helped me johnny connor just came up here
and said you're gonna do what you did last time
and there's no other way around all right connie
what'd you think honestly what'd you want to
do i'm going to ask you what you thought of the
film okay you're just going to say exactly that
connie what did you think of the film i loved
it wow this one could be on camera connie
i really loved his car what is like the common
names that dumb americans [ __ ] say all the time
they just mispronounce it for some reason when
they read it spelled a-l-m-a-s and they pronounce
it with like an i-a-l-m-i-s so they'll say all
miss even elementary school they would look at it
and say ole miss weird well i hope all those dumb
asses are watching now when i invited our shot to
come here he was like bringing my sister boom
i was like okay she must want to see this movie
or he has to do something nice true because he
messed something up oh you're like a big bad man
i'm an actually batman fan okay so what did you
think about this movie i loved it i didn't watch
any of the trailers because i just people do that
because sometimes the trailers give so much away
and i just wanted to go in and not know anything
and just really enjoy it and be excited you know
without like having any expectations let's talk
about uh zoe kravitz because she is just so hot
she looked great and i really loved her as
catwoman yeah yeah and she moved great i
loved some of the action and she just looked so
stunning well it was great getting to know you
this is our way of catching up john after so many
years it's all going to happen on camera today
it's your fault you showed up late what you
showed up later than everyone else i was
like five minutes later you didn't even really
talk to anyone true sure this i'm not even ask
your opinion i'm just gonna just stand here and
ridicule you for not being as early as everyone
else today do you like this movie i'm going to
keep it super simple for you i actually enjoyed
it thoroughly i had mid expectations would love
to see it again only had mid expectations you're
the first i've ever heard say that yeah because i
think if i over blow my expectations in comparison
to like the nolan trilogy i would be really scared
to to get my expectations not met so that's what
i was worried about how did it measure up for
you in terms of like the nolan trilogy is it
be honest man if you don't like it have some
balls and say something for a change sean
it's hard to compare because i think
they're totally different movies are
you still processing the movie yes definitely
because a lot i think that was the one thing
is the the time the amount of time that we're
spending is good but it did feel a little long
but i don't think it was too much of a big
gripe what was your favorite thing about it
greg frazier's cinematography for sure
it looks beautiful um yeah he did dune so
um and a lot of didn't even villanuev movie so
i'm like i was looking forward to how it looked
for sure yeah you were prepping imdb facts
so you can try to come on the real rejects
to impress you absolutely 100 i don't even
know who these people are i don't know about
the score i'm kind i i thought like i honestly
i thought trent rezner should have scored it
david fincher's movies so and this looks like a
david fincher movie absolutely exactly exactly
nothing really bad about it other than maybe
the the runtime me do you want to breakdance
do i have to i won't humiliate you and i just
wait do you want to break it we got chris here
now chris i know i was really looking forward
to this movie this is our honest reactions
so chris what did you think about this it
was interesting to see him struggle his way
through everything typically you see playboy
batman or playboy bruce wayne and he has his
everything figured out it's really intelligent
this one he uh he was a little sloppy as as
batman trying to figure everything out some people
really love it some people are gonna not like it
the question is what did you think about the
batman what did i uh it was good it was just
it wasn't what i expected i'll say that but i
did stay away from trailers you said it wasn't
what you expected how did you expect something
if you didn't see anything for what to expect
for it i expected the typical batman typical
bruce wayne playboy i also didn't expect uh
it was dark you know you seemed overwhelmed by
how dark it was it was dark i didn't expect it
like it was like whoa even the character the
riddler the riddler is always laughing fun
he's having fun as he's doing all these terrible
things and that just wasn't the case here well i
appreciate your honesty when you're surrounded by
people who have nothing but overwhelming praise
you had the balls to come up here and say you
know what i thought it was just all right that
takes a lot of courage yeah you guys aren't
going to do anything to me on the way outside
you never know man guys this is
taymor i've talked to taymor maybe
three times in my life i know we share a big
passionate agreement for the snyder verse
but what do you think about the batman okay i'm
going to be perfectly honest i don't think i've
enjoyed a batman movie this much since the tim
burton era i know not a popular opinion but i just
[ __ ] love like burton's visual aesthetic and i
just felt like no other directors really captured
that and i feel like this is probably the closest
we've gotten to that i appreciate that even though
it is it is grounded i think matt reeves drew
influence from like so many things because i
think there was hints of burden there were hints
of like the batman arkham games the first one to
mention the damn games and so much of the time
i think of the games during the first one right
there's certain shots that's like straight up out
of arkham knight like no one's like noticing this
brandon do you want to be in here 30 seconds
here's the only other person i've known as long
as john maybe not as much of a cinephile
but a big batman fan i know this yep it's
true now brandon despite how many ridiculous
bathroom breaks you took during this movie
yeah you didn't miss any important stuff
i was always like what did you think about
this movie i thought it was amazing i thought
it was so cool it definitely was very batman-ish
right i think the one the other one the big batman
series that happened big batman fan over yeah that
one was cool but this one was definitely darker
it kind of felt like the 90s cartoon to me it's
a common rhetoric i've heard tonight okay yeah
yeah so you're just stealing opinions down there
i waited till the end you know
that bike was a nice little tiny
nice little tiny reveal there that was
cool yeah all right cool thanks brandon
all right guys well there you have it looks like
most people liked it i would say most people love
this movie and uh thank you guys thank you
cinemark again for this catch you guys soon